siamo portati molto più facilmente a
tutelare un edificio un dipinto Che
un'opera della natura
Se pensate a un dipinto in un museo
Controlliamo la temperatura un albero a
meno che non sia così lo diamo per
scontato
E io cosa c'entro cosa c'entra un
dottore forestale e quali sono le
competenze di un dottore forestale
probabilmente a qualcuno di voi è venuto
in mente questo il Range Smith Yoghi
Bubu
io i miei colleghi Siamo abituati a
questa associazione con un altro
bellissimo lavoro che quello della
Guardia Forestale Ma le nostre
competenze sono diverse
e quali sono queste competenze e a cosa
servono queste competenze sentiamo
parlare tanto di transizione ecologica
ma per portare avanti la transizione
ecologica occorrono proprio le
competenze anche di un dottore forestale
quali
progettazione conoscenza della Botanica
conoscenza del Verde conoscenza di
economia
conoscenza di pianificazione e molto
altro
in questo momento
ricopro un ruolo di assessore al verde e
all'ambiente presso il mio comune di
Pordenone
E cosa sto facendo Sto cercando di
mettere a disposizione con i miei uffici
le mie competenze per creare un percorso
una linea che dia una direzione
certa quando si tratta di verde
e in questo caso
cosa stiamo facendo
Stiamo cercando di portare Pordenone ad
essere una città pilota
a mettere in
per poter accompagnare gli
amministratori i tecnici i progettisti
lungo un percorso metodologico ben
definito che faccia Sì che anche se si
tratta di un solo albero il progetto del
Verde abbia pari dignità di qualunque
altro progetto
ma perché questo
dobbiamo questo percorso che stiamo
portando avanti a radici profonde
dobbiamo tornare Infatti al 2013 quando
in Italia viene approvata una legge che
è la norma per la definizione degli
spazi verdi e urbani in ambiente appunto
urbano
è la prima volta che in Italia si
accende un faro sul verde per cui questa
legge è stata veramente
rivoluzionario perché appunto per la
prima volta comincia andare delle
direttive specifiche su quello che deve
essere il progetto del Verde
da qui siamo partiti perché per
realizzare le opere pubbliche ci siano
delle linee ben precise se devo
realizzare un intervento che sia una
strada che sia una scuola che sia anche
un parco dovrò conoscere il luogo in cui
lo andrò a realizzare Dovrò capire se in
quel posto Ci sono delle fragilità se ci
saranno se c'è già del Verde se quel
verde dovrà essere sacrificato se ne
potrò mettere dell'altro
dovrò conoscere a fondo il luogo in cui
io andrò a realizzare quell'opera
devo anche capire se quel luogo ha delle
criticità particolari se il portare più
persone in quel luogo creerà ulteriori
criticità se nell'ambiente circostante
ci saranno delle ripercussioni positive
o negative Semplicemente devo conoscere
devo applicare tutte le conoscenze che
che ho
dovrò anche capire se posso salvare
qualcosa o se posso o se devo
se potrò costruire qualcosa di nuovo in
quel punto lì un'altra cosa di cui avete
sentito molto parlare è il bilancio
della CO2 Ma cos'è questo bilancio della
CO2 facciamo un esempio concreto se io
dovrò andare a realizzare una nuova
strada per ridurre il traffico in quel
punto Potrebbe essere una buona idea ma
se per fare quella strada io creerò
tanti e tali impatti da far sì che
quella CO2 che io avrò prodotto per
realizzarla la batterò in 30 anni forse
dovrò fare delle riflessioni e dire è
utile farla non è utile farla oppure
Dovrò capire se con qualche intervento
del verde per cui li qui L'importanza di
avere un progettista un tecnico che di
verde ne capisca all'interno del team
progettuale Magari quei 30 anni
diventeranno 10 oppure addirittura si
azzereranno
Allora appunto diventa fondamentale che
ci sia un pool di progettisti e qualcuno
che di sostenibilità ne sappia veramente
qualcosa
le conoscenze botaniche
fitosanitarie di fito Sociologia sono
ormai fondamentali e mi consentono di
conoscere anche le funzioni che quel
verde dovrà avere se io vedevo
Progettare un ospedale Ormai abbiamo
tanti e tali dati e conoscenze che non
dobbiamo neanche andare a sperimentare
cose nuove basta attingere Ma sapete che
i malati che hanno le finestre sul verde
a parità di malattie guariscono prima i
pazienti in terapia chemioterapica hanno
bisogno di meno farmaci per controllare
il vomito
lo stesso personale sanitario in un
ambiente con del Verde Recupera in
serenità perché la funzione del verde è
il benefici che si hanno a livello
psicosomatico Ormai sono cosa nota se
devo progettare una scuola il verde
insegnerà i bambini ad approcciarsi alla
natura
ad averne rispetto
a addirittura saranno più concentrati e
addirittura impareranno con più facilità
la matematica
se devo andare a piantare degli alberi
in una zona dove c'è un elevato
Inquinamento non basta piantare alberi
così ogni specie ha la sua
caratteristica e a volte piantare la
specie sbagliata e magari la
disposizione la collocazione è sbagliata
rischio di avere addirittura un effetto
controproducente
perché continuo a parlare di pari
dignità del progetto verde ma perché se
noi progettiamo del verde ma vorremmo
sapere di quanta acqua faranno bisogno
quelle piante
vorremmo sapere quanto grande diventerà
quell'albero per poi non doverlo fare
potare con potature indecenti perché non
abbiamo tenuto conto della sua
architettura Di come sarà fra vent'anni
di come si espanderà Fra 20 anni e
allora qui torniamo al bisogno di
conoscenza e di competenza e poi dovremo
capire anche come prendersene cura la
curatela del patrimonio verde in ambito
Urbano è qualcosa di fondamentale la
parola manutenzione lasciamola gli
edifici per la materia vivente si deve
parlare di cura sempre perché non si
tratta mai solo di un albero e la
sostenibilità è un cerchio che deve
chiudersi sempre dove ogni Casella deve
andare al suo posto
tanto prendo tanto devo ridare
vi faccio anche un esempio concreto
Questo è il parco Galvani a Pordenone
con quello che vi ho detto abbiamo messo
in pratica la realizzazione quindi una
pista ciclabile il progetto originario
prevedeva l'abbattimento di Ben 90
alberi cosa abbiamo fatto abbiamo
preteso che ci fosse nel team
progettuale una figura di un tecnico del
Verde il quale con pochi accorgimenti ha
fatto sì che invece di usare una ruspa
si usasse una macchina che con l'aria
sposta la terra e abbiamo salvaguardato
gli apparati radicali abbiamo poi visto
che bastava spostare di 7 cm
quella pista e abbiamo salvato ben 90
alberi non solo siamo riusciti a
salvarne i 90 a piantarne altri 10 con
solo 7 cm Sembra semplice ma per fare
questo dietro ci sono conoscenze
e competenza
Qual è il mio sogno
il mio sogno è poter applicare nella mia
città la formula del dottore Van denbosh
che è un insegnante di selvicoltura
urbana a Vancouver in Canada e questa
formula è 330 300 cosa vogliono dire
questi numeri 3 tre sono gli alberi che
ognuno di noi dovrebbe poter vedere
dalla propria finestra
solo guardare il verde fa stare bene 30
30% di copertura Arborea in ogni
quartiere della città
vantaggi sul microclima controllo delle
acque riduzione dell'inquinamento del
rumore è sempre il benessere psicofisico
300 la distanza che dovrebbe esserci al
massimo da ogni casa a un parco credo
che qui non ci sia bisogno di spiegare
il perché
è bellissimo essere qui con voi questa
sera perché quando ormai più di 35 anni
fa mi sono iscritta a scienze forestali
ambientali sembrava un po' una persona
strana un po' originale e nessuno
nessuno se ne parlava veramente un po'
molto poco di ambiente
E qual è il messaggio che mi preme
lasciare questa sera ma uno è che le
città del futuro hanno bisogno di
competenze di sostenibilità vera e che
nessun professionista nessun tecnico e
da solo e deve unire le competenze con
gli altri e secondo messaggio è che in
realtà tutte le cose sono molto ma molto
più semplici di quello che pensiamo
Perché in fondo la natura chiede solo
una cosa quella che vogliamo tutti noi
in ogni rapporto che è il rispetto
Grazie
[Applauso]